so let's compute the curvature of a
three dimensional parametric curve and
the one I have in mind has a special
name
it's a helix and the first two
components kind of make it look like a
circle it's going to be cosine of T for
the X component sine of T for the Y
component but this is three-dimensional
and what makes it a little different
from a circle I'm going to have the last
component be T divided by five and what
this looks like we can visualize it
pretty well I'm going to go on over to
the graph of it here so this shape is
called a helix and you can sort of see
how looking from the XY planes
perspective it looks as if it's going to
draw a circle and really these lines
should all line up when you're facing it
but it's due to the perspective where
things farther away look smaller but it
would just be drawing a circle but then
the Z component because Z increases
while you're parameter T increases
you're kind of rising as if it's a
spiral staircase and now before we
compute curvature to know what we're
really going for what this represents
you kind of imagine yourself you know
maybe this isn't a road but it's like
I've like a space freeway right and
you're driving you're your spaceship
along it and you imagine that you get
stuck at some point or maybe not that
you get stuck but all of your
instruments lock and your steering wheel
locks or your joystick or however you're
steering it all just locks up and you're
going to trace out a certain circle in
space right and that circle might look
something like this so if you're
returning however you were on the helix
but then you can't do anything different
you might trace out a giant circle and
what we care about is the radius of that
circle and if you take one divided by
the radius of that circle you trace out
that's going to be the curvature that's
going to be the little cap of curvature
and of course the way that we compute it
we don't directly talk about that circle
at all but it's actually a good thing to
keep in the back of your mind the way
that we compute it is to first find a
unit tangent vector function with the
same parameter and what that means you
know if you imagine your helix kind of
spiraling spiraling through
three-dimensional space man I am not as
good an artist as the computer is when
it comes to drawing a helix put the unit
tangent vector function would be
something that gives you a tangent
vector at every given point you know
kind of the direction that you on you
spaceship are traveling and to do that
you take the derivative of your
parameterization that derivative which
is going to give you a tangent vector
but it might not be a unit tangent
vector so you divide it by its own
magnitude and that'll give you a unit
tangent vector and then ultimately the
goal that we're shooting for is going to
be to find the derivative of this
tangent vector function with respect to
the arc length so as a first step we'll
start by finding a derivative of our
parameterization function so when we
take that derivative luckily there's not
a lot of new things going on let's the
derivative so s Prime from single
variable calculus we just take the
derivative of each component so cosine
goes to negative sine negative sine of T
sine its derivative is cosine cosine of
T and then the derivative of T divided
by five is just a constant that's just 1
over 5 the way it is hard to say the
word derivative over and over say it
five times ok so that's s prime of T and
now what we need to do we need to find
the magnitude of s prime of T so what
that involves as we're taking the
magnitude s prime of T as a vector we
take the square root of the sum of the
squares of each of its components so
sine negative sine squared just looks
like sine squared sine squared of T
cosine squared cosine squared of T and
then 1/5 squared and that's just 125th
and you might notice I use a lot of
these sine cosine pairs and examples
partly because they draw circles and
lots of things are fun that involve
drawing circles but also because it has
a tendency to let things simplify
especially if you're taking a magnitude
because sine squared plus cosine squared
just equals one so this entire formula
this entire formula boils down to the
square root of 1 plus 1 divided by 25
and for this you might kind of be
thinking off to the side that that's 25
over 21
five plus one over 25
so making even more room here what that
equals is the square root of 26 divided
by 25 and just because 25 is already a
square and it kind of might make things
look nice let me write this as the
square root of 26 divided by 5 that
square root of 25 so this whole this
whole thing is the magnitude of our
derivative right and we think to
ourselves it's quite lucky that this
came out to be a constant because as we
saw with a more general formula it's
often pretty nasty and it can get pretty
bad but in this case it's just a
constant which is nice because as we go
up and we start to think about what a
unit tangent vector function for the for
the helix should be we're just going to
take the derivative function and divide
each term by that magnitude right so
it's going to look almost identical it's
going to be negative sine of T except
now we're dividing by that magnitude and
that magnitude of course is root 26 over
5 so we go up here and we say we're
dividing this by root 26 over 5 that
whole quantity and then similarly
y-component is cosine of T divided by
the quantity of the root 26 divided by 5
and the last part is 1/5 1/5 I'll put
that in parenthesis divided by that same
amount root 26 over 5 so we're just
taking the whole vector and we're
dividing it by the magnitude that it has
and we're lucky again that even though
this vector is a function and it can
depend on T the magnitude doesn't so the
the unit tangent vector function we get
as a result is relatively simple and
I'll call it it in here and then
continue on with this same line of
reasoning in the next video